hi folks and welcome to another episode
of good news gaming the show that
highlights all the uplifting and good
news stories from this week in games
just like this adorable little kid
Weston who not only watches along as his
favorite youtubers are PG try and beat
Sakura shadow star twice but he also
tries to play along because he's got his
own little controller it's so cute in
the news this week science no wait don't
go please it's actually a really cool
thing that you can do from home that
actually helps to benefit real-world
medical science research completing
levels will help scientists spot
computer errors in their sequences and
the data will help map the human gut
microbiome so the TLDR is that you can
help Medical Research by downloading the
latest borderlands 3 update and play the
new arcade machine in sanctuary 3 a
super cool initiative that you can do
from your couch I was never not going to
click on a video called dark souls but
you play it with a ring fit adventurer
mod and honestly after watching this
video I'm never gonna complain about
rings at work however again even though
they are really actually surprisingly
difficult
super Louie 64 who has previously played
Dark Souls games using other weird
controllers like a DDR dance mat and the
DK bongos respect muttered his ring Khan
to control Dark Souls 3 he has to jog on
the spot to run but I don't know he did
this to himself but this seems cruel he
has to squat to heal there you go ok
that's gonna be terrible if you want to
watch the whole video I've linked it
below it is incredible and it makes me
feel really bad about myself as a doc
Souls player because he's beating like
dancer the boreal valley with a rink on
and i had to summon for that one last
week Chris Papp suggested listing all
the free games that are available right
now and good news everyone
yes I had to get one of those in there
eventually good news everyone there are
quite a lot of free games available
right now we have a full updated list on
gamespot.com I'll link it below but for
now here are some of my
choice cuts gone home beautiful untried
for a banger Monument Valley - a
beautiful Bangor fable anniversary
relive your youth and fight in public
and also Google stadia is free for
everyone with a gmail account and you
also get two free months of Google
Stadium Pro which means if you haven't
played a game like destiny - now is your
chance to get in there and just get lost
in it you know you wanna but we all know
the best deal in gaming is game pass and
if you want to get a whole month of it
with hundreds of games available to play
it is only $1 which is frankly mad but
if we're talking about actually spending
money on games if you have a spare $5.00
Chad W Smith from last week's YouTube
comments suggested kind words love fight
chill beats - right - it's a super
unique game that's all about writing
nice letters to real people
Jordan roommate did an amazing article
on GameSpot if you want to read more
about it I'll link it below the tagline
for the game says it all really we're
all in this together sometimes all you
need are a few kind words
thank you to willpotter for sending this
one my way the Pokemon community has an
amazing initiative going on right now
and if you're playing sword and shield
you should definitely hop in john
merrick from sarah be calm is leading
the charge encouraging people to hop
into max raid battles at a specific time
every wednesday to try and bring people
together in sword and shields jury chart
250 well-known pokemon players who are
going to be live streaming all the
battles that they're taking part in and
he's also encouraging people to take
part in the optional challenges that
he's setting for example this week the
raid was easter themed so everyone was
encouraged to use pokemon that looked
like rabbits or eggs I suppose that's a
thing in Pokemon - very cool little
twist on just doing normal rage the
first one was this week and it looks
like it was a huge success if you want
to join in in the future or just follow
along there is a hashtag
community raid hour it's every Wednesday
thanks to Allison Lewis for the heads-up
on this one huge shout out to the folks
that tilta fie for their hope from home
fundraiser which is raised at the time
of this recording over 1.7 million
dollars for covered relief no doubt
you'll have seen a bunch of your
favorite youtubers posting about it but
if you want to set
your own hook from home fundraiser make
sure to check out that website obviously
it's linked below but you can set up
your own fundraiser from now up until
May 1st alright time for my favorite
part of the show
Daffy things from the internet this week
let's kick things off with some one
pixellating Justin Bieber's house to
make it look like it is from an old
school strategy game I thought this
tweet was incredible enough on its own
but to follow up where they placed it
within game perfect I've had a
conversation with my friends where we
have agreed this is the perfect week I'm
gonna admit something to you know I love
tick tock I spend an unreasonable amount
of time with tick tock
I actually curled my hair using a
technique that I saw on tick tock it's
quite worrying a lot of tick tock is not
great I'll admit that but sometimes you
find incredible gems like this video of
a guy playing beat Sabre but the song is
just a horse mashing its mouth like I've
been having kind of Utley ups and downs
this week but I have some great
colleagues David Tamayo sent me this
video that honestly had me cry laughing
at my desk so thank you to you guys and
I thought I would share it with you all
it's incredible
Wayne radio TV has a series called
half-life VIII up at the AI is
self-aware where he role plays is Gordon
Freeman
but his buds voice the NPC's I implore
you to watch it I think it is incredible
and the most inventive let's play I have
ever seen please watch it just make sure
you go a possible what's what's wrong
sir okay my passport why don't we need a
why don't what you mean a passport you
mean like a company ID I don't have a
passport I have my I have my Black Mesa
it's clutching all right and let's do a
quick roundup of more stuff from Animal
Crossing the game that continues to
knock it out of the park when it comes
to bringing people together for example
people coming together to share turnip
prices like Mel from Twitter
but now that it's been out for a few
weeks people are now starting to turn
their attention to the incredible things
they can make within the game
twitter user kuma po remade mother
inside animal crossing and the attention
to detail is out of this world thank you
to Reddit user Lautrec for providing me
with this mashup which is I just never
knew I needed it but it's so perfect I'm
playing persona 5 royal at the moment
and this mashup from Ultima Shadow X on
Twitter was really just like a Venn
diagram of things that I love that wraps
it up for this week if you have any more
funny clips from video games memes or
just nice uplifting stories put them in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lisa James games if you'd
like an invite to the GameSpot disc or
channel which is a really cool place to
be it's full of really nice people very
wholesome
probably easier to drop me a DM on
Twitter it's more yeah I'll definitely
see you then and I'll reply to you and
get you added it's not to see my
favorite place to be on the internet
right now so if you want to join let me
know but I'll get you in there
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]